بعكس ما يحسبه الكثيرون يشكل ارتفاع سعر
الذهب خبرا غير سعيدا للقطاع ككل فبالنسبه
لرفعت صبري صاحب متجر المصوغات ينعكس هذا
ليس فقط على قله المبيعات ولكن على قله
ربحيته هو الاخر كتاجر
بس عشان الاسعار العاليه دي فبتحاول
تشتريه على اساس ان قيمه الجنيه بتقل
فيقول لك يعني ممكن اشتريها خليها في
الدهب افضل
ناحيه البحث عن مخزون القيمه في اوقات
التضخم انعكس على رؤيتهم لشراء الذهب او
غيره من الاصول في حاله ان انا استثمر لا
سبائكهات لا اقتنع عقارات
ذهب
لان العقار بيزيد اعلى من الذهب اللي
قدامك
زي العمله الاجنبيه ارتفاع سعر الذهب في
السوق المحليه تزمن مع تراجع سعر الجنيه
امام الدولار الامر الذي زاد من الطلب
عليه كمخزون للقيمه او زينه وخزينه كما
يحب ايهاب واصف ان يطلق على هذا المعدن
النفيس لكنه في الوقت نفسه يشعر بالقلق
على مستقبل العماله الحرفيه الماهره في
مصر في تاثير على عدد الامانه كبيره وفيه
هروب كان همم في 2011 للعماله ال- ال-
الحنفيه كبير كانوا بيهربوا من القطاع
للعدم احساسهم بالامان والاستقرار في
القطاع بس النهارده احنا عندنا الامان
والاستقرار ولكن عندنا ارتفاعات الاسعار
وهذا فتح الحديث عن التركيز في التصدير
للحفاظ على العماله المدربه والماهره وهو
ما جعل شعبه الذهب تطالب الحكومه بالغاء
رسم التسمين الذي يبلغ نصف في المئه من
قيمه المشغولات فهل تشكل هذه النسبه
البسيطه تفارقا الى هذا الحد هو يفرم
معانا كتير طبعا لانه هو هيخرجني بره حيز
المنافسه من بعض الدول وبعدين احنا
المنافسه النهارده قويه جدا النصف% بيشكل
عائق كبير علينا ان احنا نظهر بلس ان في
بعض الدول بتدي دعم على الصادرات احنا
مصري ما بتتعاملش مع الذهب بدعم ابدا توقف
تسعيره الذهب في السوق المصريه نظرا لعدم
وجود معروض من السبائك التي يسعى الجميع
الان لشرائها وان استمر بيعه المشغولات
على اسعار لم يصل اليها جرام الذهب في مصر
من قبل تامر ناصر العربيه القاهره